Top commanders
say Russian
forces are increasing
their attacks on Bakhmut
as the Ukrainian military remains
determined to keep Russia
from capturing the city by Tuesday.
When Moscow holds its World
War to Victory Day Parade.
Now, Ukraine says
Russia is doing everything possible
to take back,
including sending in more forces.
And those forces include their fighters.
Just days ago,
the head of the Russian mercenary group
had threatened
to pull his man out of the fight
because of a lack of ammunition.
He now claims
his fighters are advancing
and as they wait for more supplies.
CNN's Sam
Kiley has our update now from Kiev.
Fighting continues
to be bloody and merciless
in the east of the country, in particular
around the city of parliament,
where the Ukrainians have suggested
that it's possible
that the Wagner group
or elements
supporting the fighting group
have even been using
incendiary devices in that battle.
This coming as the leader
of the mercenary organization
is backtracked
on his threat
to leave the city
and hand over to Chechen fighters.
This is very much part
of an ongoing soap opera, effectively
led by Mr.
Prigozhin,
who has been tweeting
and making public statements
since effectively
the beginning of this war.
Highly critical of the Kremlin
and particularly
the Russian Ministry of Defense.
He now says that he is getting
the ammunition that he needs
so he won't be pulling his troops out
for the foreseeable future.
But all eyes really are on where and when
or even if the Ukrainians
are going to be launching
a summer offensive.
There have been mass troop movements.
There is a lot of talk
from the Ukrainians
about an offensive,
but no real signs yet
on the ground
that anything is especially imminent.
Sam Kiley, CNN, in Kiev.
Joining me now from Washington,
retired US
Air Force colonel and CNN
military analyst Cedric Leighton.
Good to have you weigh in on
these issues.
We've had quite a few days, though,
Wagner and group leader,
he made those dramatic threats
to pull out of BUK.
Much turned out
it was quite a performance.
Right.
It looks like his troops are staying put.
Does this incident
give you any insight into what's going on
with either
the volunteer group
or the Russian military?
Well, Paula, I think it's
you know, it's
kind of the battle of the tantrums,
if you will.
And in this particular case,
Ghosn's tantrum
seems to have won the day for him.
In other words,
he gets to get weapons and ammunition,
gets a resupply line to,
you know, his troops in Bermuda.
That didn't appear
to have that good of a resupply line.
And he gets to stay in that
horrible meat grinder.
So in some ways, you know,
it might
be considered a victory for pragmatism,
but in other ways, it's
a Pyrrhic victory because,
you know, staying in that meat grinder,
it doesn't
do anybody
any favors and least of all him.
Yeah.
But there seemed
when I say that it's a poor performance.
I'm not trying to be trite.
It seemed that
it was a message to someone.
And yet if you think all he wanted from
that was ammunition, well,
that would be pretty
naive to think that it was clearly some
kind of propaganda purpose.
Absolutely.
Well, there is propaganda
and there's a power struggle
going on, Paula.
And what this basically means to me
is that Prigozhin let it be known
that he has a military element
that could be withdrawn
and could potentially put at risk
Russia's front line.
And if that front line had collapsed,
that would have been a calamity
where the Russian forces
So what Prigozhin is doing
is he's flexing his muscles in a way.
He is in a position where he can,
in essence, complain and make sure that
he gets
what he wants in this particular case.
But he is basically vying
for as much power as he can
possibly get right And that gives us turn
turns our attention now
to Ukraine's counter offensive.
It could start as early as this week.
Do you think expectations are too high
at this point,
especially if what Ukraine is looking for
is a decisive blow to the Russian
military in this war?
Yeah, if you're
going to mount
a decisive blow in an operation like this
or in a conflict like this,
there's got to be an element of surprise
here.
And, you know,
right now,
it seems to me at least that we have
telegraphed way too much.
The Ukrainians have telegraphed
way too much.
The West has telegraphed
way too much
that this offensive is going to happen.
And the only thing that's
just ignoring the specific details
as to time and place.
But we believe it's going to happen
this week.
We believe it's going to happen
probably in the south and we believe it's
going to affect the approaches to Crimea.
So that is
a major area
that shouldn't be
a big surprise to the Russians.
But if the Ukrainians have learned
mobility warfare,
if they've learned combined arms
operations,
putting all the elements
of a military force
together in a coordinated fashion,
then they could
still achieve some successes,
but they won't be as dramatic
as they would have been
had there been the element of surprise.
Yeah, it's such a good point. Right?
We've been talking about this for months,
it seems now.
And I have to ask you strategically,
the US, the allies, have they given
Ukraine enough capability at this point?
And has it arrived in time
Well, it's mixed.
You know, the verdict on
that is definitely mixed.
I think
that some of the capabilities,
such as the Patriot missile system
which reportedly has shot down
a commercial hypersonic missile,
that's a major plus for the Ukrainians.
However,
they're only going to be two batteries
two Patriot batteries in Ukraine.
They will need far more than that
in order to mount
an effective
air defense and missile defense
for their country.
And the other thing that, of course, is
missing is
required quantity of tanks
and, of course, aircraft.
The Ukrainians want the M16.
They're not getting the F-16
until after all of this is done,
if at all.
And that, of course, will provide them
with a significant
lack of capability
at this particular point.
And that could have
a significant impact
on their ability to perform.
Yeah.
And it'll be interesting
to see
what the blowback is from Ukraine,
if and when that happens.
Again, some pivotal months
ahead for sure.
As the weather warms up in Ukraine.
Retired U.S.
Air Force Colonel Cedric
Leighton, thanks so much.
Really appreciate it.
And what's the latest
on the strikes Nick, and the presence
of Russian forces in battle much as well.
Some question about that in the weekend.
Yes, certainly
the Eastern Front continues
to be very active.
Where we're standing here,
we can hear the sounds of artillery
quite clearly.
In the distance here.
So the east is very active.
And of course, particularly, in fact,
Ukrainian officials and military
are concerned about the potential
of a Russian push at the last minute
to try to take control of it completely
before those victory day
parades in Moscow on or
on the 9th of May tomorrow.
So there is,
if you will,
perhaps a little more tension
along the front lines in the east
about Russia and Russia's intent.
But, of course,
all of that will be
will be valuable information
for the Ukrainians
so that they can sort of determine
if the Russians make a big last minute
push for back.
How strong is it
where their strengths,
where the weaknesses
are along the southern front?
Again, the much expected possible
offensive that
the government
officials sometimes
call a military campaign here,
that Russian expectation
is that that's perhaps
going to get underway sometime soon.
No indication from Ukrainian officials
about when or where that may start.
But the strikes on Kiev, significant
perhaps in the number 35 drones,
that was a significant number
significant for the Ukrainians
that they were able
to shoot them all down and
some missiles getting through in Odessa.
Again, it's key
that seems to have the strongest
air defenses.
We've heard Ukrainian officials
say that they think
that recently Russia
has been testing their air
defenses to see where their weaknesses
could be.
But in the east, where we are
very distinctive,
heavy shelling continue continuing.
Nick in the east, thank you.
And clear,
we have Russia's victory day
coming up tomorrow.
The propaganda parallels for Russia
are quite strong
because this was marking 1945
the Soviet defeat of the Nazis.
And they've been alleging the pretext
for their invasion of Ukraine
were Nazi elements
and a new kind of fascism in Ukraine.
Given that it's so many months on
and Russia still
hasn't got the decisive victory
it promised at the beginning,
what's the importance of this
in terms of morale
and propaganda in the country?
So a victory day,
I mean, you just cannot overstate
its importance in Russia.
It is probably the
biggest day of the year.
It used to be, by the way,
something that
Russia marked in conjunction
with the West was
they fought together
against Nazi Germany.
I was there in 2005
that ages me a little bit, but
that was in the US president at the time.
George W Bush also attended
it was the 60th anniversary.
2010 Western troops
even marched alongside Russian troops
in that parade in Moscow.
So we see obviously in play
the complete destruction of Russia's
relations with the West.
No foreign leaders there.
But I think really significant this year
is that there's been some scaling
back of the Victory Day parade.
We've seen a lot of regions, particularly
the ones closest to Ukraine, either
canceling parades
or removing some element,
things like fireworks displays,
citing security concerns,
in some cases, others
citing proximity to Ukraine.
One particular
region said
that they didn't have
military units or equipment.
So that is potentially telling.
And I think this is just one more way in
which this war
is really hitting home
and hitting
where it hurts
because this is a huge patriotic
importance to Russians.
Sebastian, thank you so much.